Madeline Klein Is the Gen Zed American
actress who's having a big moment thanks
to her role as Sarah Cameron on Outer
Banks and as whiskey in Glass Onion a
former model herself she knows how to
serve a look pulling off some gorgeous
fits on various magazine covers and
getting gold stars at her first official
net I'm Madeline Klein and I'm going to
share with you everything I eat in a
deck so what does a dietitian think
about how 2023's it girl eats food
Diaries get at me hey everyone I'm Abby
sharp welcome to Abby's kitchen
[Music]
thank you
I'm a little offended that my own food
Diaries didn't lead to an immediate call
from Harper's Bazaar I mean I know
Mercury is in retrograde so my phone is
probably just like not working properly
and like email and Instagram DM
something like lots of reasonable
explanations but anyway we are back for
another celebrity wedding a day review
and today is brought To Us by Madeline
Klein but a quick reminder to check out
my disclaimer in the description below
and please if you're not already
subscribed hit that subscribe button
follow me on Tick Tock and Instagram and
if you haven't already checked out my
membership page we got a new membership
program that is not replacing the
freebies that you already have grown to
love and expect from me here at Abby's
kitchen so this is just bonus content
Early Access q and A's all that good
stuff for about 4.99 per month so if you
guys want to help a girl out check out
the link in the description let me hop
in here to discuss one of my all-time
favorite foods cereal if you guys watch
any of my videos you know that cereal is
its own food group over here but as
we've often discussed in my videos about
Hunger crushing combos a typical bowl of
sugary cereal keeps me full for like a
whole 30 minutes delicious but I'm
pretty much just as hungry afterwards as
I was before I ate it so when I
discovered magic spoon cereal I was like
okay this ticks all the boxes you get
childlike Nostalgia with fun flavors and
the iconic cereal crunch but with 13 to
14 grams of protein per serving and a
lot less sugar than our childhood faves
they're also gluten-free and grain free
with no artificial sweeteners flavors or
colors my favorites are the peanut
butter and the Frosted but they also
have cocoa for chocolate lovers and
fruity for the nostalgic experience
sometimes I just eat it straight out of
the box for an on-the-go snack or for a
solid meal I serve with lots of fruit
and hemp hearts on top for some extra
carbs and healthy fats oh and the peanut
butter on top of a smoothie bowl or
oatmeal for a little crunch factor and
protein
so good so if you can also crush a box
of cereal any day anyway check out my
link in the description or go to
magicspoon.com Abby sharp to get a
variety pack and use my promo code Abby
sharp to get five dollars off any order
all right I'm hungry Madeline let's do
this first thing I do when I wake up I
usually wake up pretty thirsty so I'll
probably chug some water okay this
checks out in no other circumstance
would we go like eight hours with a drop
of water and expect not to be thirsty as
so yeah chug away girl
my go-to is usually coffee but I'm
trying to not drink coffee on an empty
stomach however I am addicted recently
I've been putting some oat milk just
regular old oat milk if you guys watch
my channel you know that this is not a
new claim we see this often from
Wellness influencers Tick Tock
nutritionists and the general lay person
or celebrity but to refresh the common
clean here is that coffee on an empty
stomach increases your stress hormone
cortisol and cortisol is often
associated with weight gain particularly
belly fat which is actually true but
it's not like your regular cup of coffee
in the morning is making you gain weight
while some research has found that
coffee can increase cortisol levels both
at rest and during periods of stress
other research has found no increase in
cortisol levels at all and this
individual variation likely has to do
with one's sensitivity to stress anxiety
high blood pressure and most importantly
their tolerance to caffeine here's the
really important piece of information
that Wellness influencers don't tell you
the impact of caffeine on cortisol
levels seems to diminish with regular
caffeine consumption in other words if
you regularly drink coffee within an
hour or so of waking up like most human
beings your body adapts to this habit it
learns like no this is not a bear coming
at me
it's just a double double in a bagel and
this significantly blunts the transient
effects on cortisol we don't actually
have any research looking at the
specific effects of an empty stomach
versus not though it would make sense
that having some food in the stomach may
help to buffer the effects and if not
the cortisol effects then at least any
potential GI side effects and Madeleine
actually didn't say why she was trying
to not consume coffee on an empty
stomach it may be that straight up
caffeine upsets her tummy or gives her
the runs
you all right but regardless I think
just adding a bit of nutrition via like
some milk like the oat milk as she
describes doing can definitely also help
to buffer some of those effects at the
end of the day this is highly
individualized and if you're not feeling
any kind of stress response after your
coffee your body is likely metabolizing
things just fine and is highly unlikely
to cause hormonal dysregulation so this
is just like a long-winded way of me
saying drink your coffee how and when
you like it next
and then I'll sip on that for a while
maybe put in the microwave a couple
times this is so relatable like this
coffee right here has been Zapped three
times
but it Bears to question is microwaving
your coffee bad for your health
so let's do a little microwave myth
busting number one microwaving does not
make your food radioactive so we don't
need to worry about some kind of like
Chernobyl type situation it's a hazmat
suit microwaving also doesn't zap
nutrients out of food it might slightly
reduce nutrients but it's actually one
of the best ways to preserve nutrients
compared to other heating or cooking
methods it does however affect some of
the volatile compounds in coffee because
heating increases the quinic and caffeic
acid which is really astringent and
bitter tasting So Pro tip from a girl
who likes her coffee and likes it really
hot it is hot we're finally getting hot
even if you're at home try drinking it
out of a really good insulated to-go cup
I probably should be taking my own
advice here sometimes I wake up really
hungry on some days the signature is
going to In and Out for breakfast in and
out in coffee Breakfast of Champions a
double double with everything on it plus
chopped chilies animal style fry and a
Diet Coke Oh California I am super
jealous of your web other but I'm mostly
jealous of your access to animal style
Burgers obviously you don't need a
dietitian to tell you that this isn't
the most healthy breakfast like it's
high in sodium fat and additives and low
in fiber without really much veg Insight
but to satisfy those with a big appetite
when a bowl of porridge just won't do I
think it's totally fine in moderation
all meals have redeeming qualities and
this meal she cited has over 40 grams of
satisfying protein and as I always
discuss focusing on a protein-rich
breakfast is key for body composition
weight management and appetite
management throughout the day other days
well maybe I'll do a breakfast sandwich
or oatmeal maybe a smoothie see balance
perfectly balanced this whole thing
should be I appreciate a celebrity who
doesn't make a huge deal out of having
like a higher calorie meal in the
context of a more nutritious high fiber
diet and I also appreciate that she
isn't giving any disclaimers with these
choices like when I want to be good I
have a smoothie and when I'm having a
cheat day I have a burger and fries Etc
it just like a list of possibilities
based on accessibility and Cravings we'd
love to see it this is normal eating
usually I'll forget about lunch until I
get hungry which is probably maybe like
four and I'll realize I haven't eaten
then I will probably post made something
a sandwich of some type for a lot of
people eating intuitively is this
experience of literally not thinking
about food until the sirens are going
off full blast I'm hungry
me too make something and for these
people this works just fine like I'm
sure a lot of you watching must think
wow it must be so liberating to never
think about food until you're absolutely
starving so there's definitely benefits
of operating this way but for others
this is just never going to be possible
and may not even be necessarily ideal or
advantageous if we wait until we're
ravenous to eat we often end up making
less mindful decisions about our food
choices usually based on convenience and
Desperation rather than self-care we
also might end up with more severe dips
and spikes in our energy headaches GI
distress and temporary spikes and
cortisol which physically doesn't feel
so good and generally speaking I like to
think of our hunger kind of like a gas
gauge and I usually recommend trying to
start eating around a three or four and
to try to prevent yourself from going
all the way to a 10. like a Thanksgiving
level of stuffed doesn't feel so good
usually I get a tuna melt from John
Garden it's their standard I've asked
them a few times to make it extra toasty
but I really love a tuna melt that's
been a big thing recently love this
journey for us like tuna melts are so
iconically American to me I only have
tuna melts in the states I don't know
why but we got lots of protein in the
tuna fat in the Mayo and the cheese and
carbs in the bread Pro tip up the fiber
by going with a seeded Rye or whole
grain bread and try to ask for a little
salad on the side for some extra veg if
I'm going to snack especially on set I'm
probably going to go with hot Cheetos or
salt and vinegar chips those snap pea
crisps good old vegetables and hummus
also delicious love the variety here and
actually those snap pea crisps are a
snack that I actually buy a lot here at
home they got a really short ingredient
list starting with green peas and
they've got four grams of fiber and five
grams of protein per serving which when
compared to like hot Cheetos for example
is pretty good for a crunchy snack plus
my kids are obsessed and I can get them
at the dollar store we love that and
then for dinner because usually I wait
to eat lunch later I a good green soup
Erawan has a really really great green
soup that I like a lot it's like lemony
it's got like broccoli and kale and
green things I imagine it's pretty
healthy lemon orzo soup is really yummy
like lemon chicken and orzo lots of ball
soup potato and leek soup chili the
possibilities are endless here totally
makes sense to be craving a lighter
dinner after a larger breakfast and a
very light lunch plus I don't know where
she's ordering her tuna melts but where
I go in Florida there's got to be like
two whole cans of tuna per sandwich it's
a lot of food but tuna aside some days
you just want soup I love soup and if
you don't want to spend 18 on soup at
airwon and you also don't have time to
make it here is my little nutritious
budget friendly hack take a can of your
favorite soups like chicken noodle
vegetable butternut squash broccoli
whatever ideally a lower sodium variety
but if not it's gonna be okay then turn
it into a stew or a stoop as Rachel Ray
used to call it by throwing in whatever
leftovers you've got in the fridge so
rotisserie chicken steamed or roasted
veggies whole grain noodles or rice
canned beans frozen kale or spinach
whatever I got a bunch of ideas for
upgrading canned soup in one of my
really old videos so you can definitely
check that out if you're looking for
some really fast budget-friendly meal
solution but yeah it might be like
summer outside but it's soup season all
year round in my books
I really love to just make a charcuterie
board basically just an adult lunchable
my perfect board would be Marie or Brie
adjacent cheese firm white cheese I love
to have like a little bit of salami
prosciutto obviously crackers fruit on
there I love to have like a fig Jam or a
cherry jam pop-up of like a you know
Lactaid pill I can just imagine a cheese
board where instead of nuts you just
like aesthetically sprinkle in some
lactate pills and again a girl after my
cheese loving heart love the idea of an
adult lunchable for those nights when
you just do not want to have to turn the
oven on and you feel like having a
snacky snack dinner rather than a meat
starch veg you know and I don't know I
think that a charcuterie board can be
inherently very well balanced we got
protein fat carbs veggies what's not to
love as for the Lactaid this is one of
the two most evidence-based digestive
enzymes on the mark Market the other of
which is be gnome and while yes
digestive enzymes absolutely can and do
help people with functional gut
disorders or intolerances not all
supplements out there on the market are
legit or evidence-based or even
appropriate for every Tick-Tock
influencer selling them I mean
ultimately you should try to work with a
registered dietitian to determine the
root cause of your symptoms first and
determine if digestive enzymes would
even be a good fit but if lactose
intolerance is the issue we do have
evidence that taking supplemental
lactase AKA lactate can absolutely help
I think it's worth a try if you love
your cheese how much
speaking of orange wine I found one
recently that's really lovely it's
called Ravina usually that's my go-to
but if I'm feeling spiffy I'll probably
do like a martini like a dirty martini
orange is definitely the new pink so
here's a little factoid that you can
bust out at your next dinner party
orange wine is produced by allowing the
skin and seeds of the grate to ferment
in the juice so like red wine it's rich
in antioxidants like campheral corsarin
catechins and Resveratrol likely more so
than white wine where the skin and seeds
are removed before fermentation we do
know that these compounds have health
benefits but we also need to weigh them
against the risk of alcohol consumption
in general which is why we generally see
a j-shaped curve in the literature
people here in Canada are freaking out
because the new Canadian guidelines
slash the recommended weekly drinks from
10 for women and 15 for men to just two
per week based on the most up-to-date
research I love myself some wine but I
do personally agree with the standard
for a multitude of reasons sleep Mental
Health weight management chronic disease
risk Etc so I personally see wine as
something to be enjoyed in modern
creation yes it has antioxidants but we
probably shouldn't be aiming to get the
bulk for antioxidants through booze just
saying I love olives no blue cheese
absolutely ever blue cheese is not
allowed on the charcuterie it is not
allowed in Olive sorry no but I like
olives I am also not a blue cheese girly
but it does have some unique health
benefits over other cheese so let's talk
about it for example so blue
gluten teeth up to 4 700 bioactive
peptides one of which is called
spermidine which has been shown to help
reduce the risk of heart disease this
has actually LED researchers to
hypothesize that blue cheese may be one
of the key reasons for low
cardiovascular mortality in countries
like France also dairy fat is not as bad
as we once thought in fact a
comprehensive review of 16 studies found
that consuming full fat Dairy including
cheese was associated with the lower
risk of obesity while another review
with almost a million people found
neutral or a slight reduced risk of
heart disease that said there's really
no point choking down very very stinky
cheese if it doesn't bring you Joy but
if it does I see no reason to avoid it
either I'm not a major dessert person
every once in a while I'll get a craving
for dessert and I really love there's a
bakery nearby that does little mini rum
Baba cakes and it's just these like
sponge cakes soaked in rum and there's
just a little bit of like a cream
filling and they're so yummy and they're
tiny and just enough I also love
tiramisu these are definitely not
dessert person desserts because they are
inherently a little bitter and boozy and
while having a non-restrictive intuitive
eating approach can absolutely help to
reduce the likelihood of obsessing or
pining over sweets there's also a
genetic component here too research has
linked a particular variant of the
fgf21 gene to being more likely to have
a sweet tooth possibly related to neural
responses to reward interestingly the
researchers found that this particular
allyl is associated with a lower total
body fat percentage though this
population does tend to have greater
risk of weight accumulation in the
midsection plus a higher risk of high
blood pressure this is emerging research
but it may be used in the future for
different nutrigenomic drug therapies
which is something that I personally
find really fascinating so I love this
day I love that we didn't have to hear
about cheat days or detoxes or really
any pseudoscience that explanation for
why Madeline eats what she eats plus I
got to spend part of my work day reading
about orange wine and I love feeling
fancy like that
you already know and on that note that's
all that I have for you guys today if
you like this video be sure to give it
the thumbs up leave me a comment below
on who or what you'd like to see me
discuss next subscribe to the channel
and I'll see you next time on Abby's
kitchen bye